[Musique]
bonjour à tous le figaro vous propose
aujourd'hui une destination touristique
un peu particulière nous sommes à
tchernobyl en ukraine est ce que vous
voyez derrière moi c'est le sarcophage
du réacteur numéro 4 celui qui a explosé
en 1986 dans l'un des pires accidents
nucléaires de l'histoire vous avez
peut-être vu la série tchernobyl qui a
un succès monstre déjà considéré par
certains comme la meilleure série de
tous les temps et qu'il dope d'ailleurs
le tourisme ici on va pouvoir voir les
lieux de la catastrophe de nos propres
yeux répondre à quelques questions de
sécurité et d'éthique qui se pose
évidemment ici et puis enfin pourquoi
pas rencontrer les fans de la série
ce gigantesque dôme métallique a été
placée sur le réacteur 4 pour contenir
toutes les parties n'est plus
radioactive après l'explosion survenue
le 26 avril 1986 à 1h23 du matin dans
une urss à quelques années de son
effondrement
c'est effectivement ce qui marque le
plus dans la zone d'exclusion la
végétation qui est partout et les
quelques 5000 personnes qui travaillent
encore ici chaque jour pour la
maintenance des lieux la sécurité les
casernes de pompiers et la cantine du
coin aussi par exemple
autre point fort de cette journée la
visite du bâtiment qui est juste
derrière moi c'est en réalité une
garderie qui a été bien évidemment
évacués et abandonné après la
catastrophe les guides nous ont bien
prévenu ici et vous allez le constater
la radioactivité est bien plus
importante et le compteur geiger sa
folle à quelques endroits
tout ce que l'on voit ici est d'époque
même si les poupées les jouets les
vêtements ont parfois été ramassés puis
replacé pour reconstituer une ambiance
en ressortant on nous indique une touche
connu pour être très radioactive un
compteur geiger prêté à chaque visiteur
pour la journée permet de faire ses
propres relevés joint par téléphone en
amont le directeur adjoint de l'institut
de recherche en sécurité nucléaire nous
assurer qu'il n'y a pas de risque
sanitaire a passé une journée à
tchernobyl l'itinéraire classique de
votre visite à tchernobyl vous conduira
sûrement aux radars pendant l'ère
soviétique
les russes ont profité de la zone
stratégique autour de la centrale et du
camouflage idéal de ces bois pour monter
tout un système de détection de missiles
intercontinentaux qui culmine à 150
mètres de haut le système de détection
aura finalement fonctionné assez peu
d'abord il a fallu le reconfigurer car
ils déréglait les systèmes gps de tous
les avions de ligne à la ronde
et puis évidemment il fut abandonné
après la catastrophe on peut visiter
aujourd'hui la structure le couloir sous
lequel repose et on peut aussi y croiser
d'autres touristes qui ont vu la série
de tchernobyl
nous sommes maintenant à pripiat c'est
peut-être le moment le plus poignant de
cette journée dans la zone d'exclusion
c'est une ville autrefois habité de
50000 habitants des ingénieurs des
personnels administratifs beaucoup
travaillé d'ailleurs dans la centrale
qui n'est qu'à 3 kilomètres d'ici et
c'est surtout une ville qui a été
évacuée trente six heures après
l'explosion et qui est devenue une ville
fantôme vous allez vous en rendre compte
la végétation a repris ici tous ses
droits
la ville est aujourd'hui en ruine et on
redoute plus l'écroulement des murs que
la radioactivité des lieux dans un
ancien centre culturel on tombe sur les
vestiges d'une piscine municipale une
salle de spectacle des fresques de
l'époque des inscriptions en syrie nique
de l'ère soviétique
un peu plus loin on découvre une aire de
jeu où les enfants de pripiat jouets
d'autrefois
[Musique]
c'est la fin de notre tour dans la zone
d'exclusion de tchernobyl une visite
vous l'avez vu parfois sous les trombes
d'eau et parfois au soleil on préfère
retenir le silence saisissant dans
certains lieux laissés à l'abandon
plutôt que cette passion un peu curieuse
de placer son compteur geiger aux
endroits les plus radioactifs de la zone
ceci dit on n'a pas vu de comportement
irrespectueux et un mot enfin sur le
tourisme qui est en plein développement
ici quarante mille personnes se sont
déplacées à tchernobyl depuis le 1er
janvier 2019
nous sommes en juillet l'année dernière
à la même date il était que 20000 un
tourisme qui a doublé probablement à
cause de la série même si ce n'est pas
la seule raison merci